[Music]
hey everyone
i just wanted to make this really brief
video and discuss the situation with
fantastic piece 3
and the replacement of johnny depp
obviously unless you live under a rock
you've probably seen the headlines
surrounding depp
and his resignation from the film
franchise given the depth plays
grindelwald the primary antagonist this
obviously leaves a huge hole in the
franchise
however since his vacancy there have
been a lot of names thrown up in the air
regarding his replacement although one
name appears to have shown up more than
any other
and that name is mass mickelson where
rumors were previously circulating
surrounding his acceptance of the role
mazz released a statement recently
explaining that these were just rumors
and that he hadn't been approached by
warner brothers just yet he didn't
explicitly express interest in the role
but he did say that he was waiting for a
call from them however
just today warner brothers released a
statement explaining
that maz has officially been cast as the
dark wizard grindelwald maz has been
in a plethora of films including rogue
one a star wars story
hannibal casino royale and many others
and i think that he'll be a valuable
asset to the fantastic beasts franchise
the third film is currently under
production at least in studios
just outside of london and the film is
expected to be released in the summer of
the filmmakers have had a hard time
sticking with release deadlines so far
so hopefully this doesn't get extended
any longer all of the other actors are
still on board
jude law dumbledore eddie redmayne newt
dan fogler
jacob etc so i'm excited for a good film
that's it for this brief update video
i hope you all have a good day until
next time remember there is plenty to be
learned
even from a bad teacher what not to do
how not to be